the government is overwhelmed by the
thousands of migrants at our southern
border
border patrol is set to officially
announce this week a
staggering number of apprehensions for
the month of february
more than one hundred thousand that's up
almost 30 percent from january it's
gotten so bad
dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas is now
begging employees via email
to help volunteer and quote provide
needed humanitarian support along the
southwest border and relief for our cbp
colleagues that call for back off is a
far cry from the administration's
long-held stance that there's
no immigration crisis
the men and women of the department of
homeland security
are working around the clock seven days
a week
to ensure that we do not have a crisis
at the border
[Applause]
at this point is this a crisis at the
border look i don't think we need to sit
here and put new
labels on what we have already conveyed
is challenging
joining me now republican senator from
louisiana john kennedy senator how are
you
i'm well trey what the heck's going on
down at the southern border
seems pretty predictable
in my judgment trey this is a prime
example
of why so many americans
think there's no intelligent life in
washington
one need not be clairvoyant to have seen
this coming
i mean what did president biden think
was going to happen
what did my democratic friends in
congress think was going to happen
for four years they fought the trump
administration
like a bunch of myrmidons in its efforts
to
to secure the border um
president bidens and his democratic
colleagues mantra was
you're all a bunch of racists enforcing
immigration laws is racist
vetting people at the border is racist
i can tell you what the message to the
world was
from president biden and the democratic
party we believe in open borders that's
certainly the message
that the people of central america
central america heard that's what
the smugglers and the coyotes and the
drug dealers heard
and so here they are and they're going
to keep coming
and they're not going to stop and
president biden has a decision to make
he's either going to enforce america's
immigration laws
and devote the resources to do so
or he isn't now
if he if he listens to the american
people trey
i think i know what they will tell him
the american people
are not anti-immigrant i'm certainly not
the american people support legal
immigration i certainly do
uh america invites over a million of our
world's neighbors
every year legally to become american
citizens
i support that and i'm flattered by it
as i've said before when's the last time
you heard of somebody trying
to sneak into china other than from
north korea
people want to come here but but that's
legal immigration american people
also believe that illegal immigration
is illegal duh
and they don't think that vetting people
at the border is racist
they think it's prudent so president
biden's got a decision to make and we
do have a crisis it's not a challenge
it's uh it's not a problem it's not a
bump in the road
it is a full blown crisis that he can
solve
if a he's willing to follow the rule of
law and
enforce america's immigration laws and b
he's willing to devote
the resources to do so and i can tell
you that congress will commit those
resources
if he's willing
senator i i'm one of those nerds that
actually watched merrick garland's
confirmation hearing on the judiciary
committee i thought it was very civil
got a little bit of time left let me ask
you it seems like the path may be
a little rockier for some of the other
senior doj officials not named judge
garland is that fair
yes and and let me tell you what i've
noticed i don't want to talk
specifically about one nomination but
there seem to be two main
characteristics to serve in president
biden's cabinet number one
you've got to worship at the altar of
climate change
the people that he's nominated don't see
climate change
as a discrete scientific problem
they see it as a religion and number two
it it appears at least most if not all
of his nominees
are obsessed with race
and gender and sexuality
and i think many of them think america
is wicked it was wicked in its origins
it's more wicked today that most
americans are racist
most americans are misogynistic most
americans are sexist
and most americans are homophobic and
that's not the america that i live in
and uh i'm afraid that where this is
going to lead
i hope i'm wrong uh is quotas
which are illegal which are
unconstitutional
and which will make a mocking mockery of
the american dream
sarah kennedy i cannot thank you enough
for joining us we'll be watching i at
least will be watching the other
confirmation hearings and watching you
on the judiciary committee thank you so
much for being with us
thanks true